[Music]
my name is Victor and I'm an introvert
and being an introvert just really means
that I'm shy and I don't really like to
talk to people much but what I do love
is illa trying dance music and for the
last three years I've been going to this
music festival called Electric Daisy
Carnival also called EDC and I've been
going with my girlfriend at the time the
past three years this year I just moved
to LA or were no longer together and the
only reason why I didn't consider going
by myself is because my favorite DJ
Porter Robinson is going to perform
there
I think I'm just gonna do it I'm really
nervous because it's a huge space on the
Las Vegas Motor Speedway there's 200,000
attendees that go every year and I'm not
gonna stick on one of them we will see
how I fare at Electric Daisy Carnival by
myself
just got to my hotel room all this is
for me
so usually I'd be getting ready in the
bathroom with my girlfriend we listened
to music dancing instead about myself
but I'm almost ready to go for the first
day no nervous the shuttle ride too easy
it was pretty lonely but when I got up
and saw that welcome sign I started to
get butterflies and then this happened
II D C is a huge place in a ticket for
an entrance gate five for the shadows
dropping off all the way across the
motor speed with to cosmic meadow where
Alania would be playing so naturally I
ran like a Batman
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so how is pretty much dancing by myself
the whole time but I had a lot of fun
and that's my first time actually seeing
iminium they have to say he's probably
my second favorite DJ behind put her on
to now so good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
zette is always a fun time but when you
played clarity I just got really sad
because my ex and I sing that song a lot
thankfully during the audience set
though I met these cool people who
basically were singing along every song
with me word for word and then we just
pretty much all danced together for
that's the night and it was pretty damn
awesome not gonna lie but I just woke up
to attacks from them saying that they
won't be at EDC anymore
somebody came at my work and they had
Lee so back to square one yay today is
the day Otto röhm attend day two so
freaking excited friends and old friends
we have fun oh my god it can't contain
my excitement
[Music]
this was my seventh time seeing Porter
and have to say hands down this was the
best show he's ever played musically and
visually and because of that I was just
so focused on recording to set not
wanting to talk to anyone or dance with
anyone but instead just being stuck in
my own world holding my GoPro ultimately
becoming the introvert that I'd told
myself I would break out of and then the
piano part for shelter came on and I
just started crying because I was so
beautiful if I don't nail on the coffin
was when he finished with language which
is my first idea of love song with my ex
I couldn't take it anymore I had to
leave and now I could this freaking
hotel room all myself about ready to go
for the last day I think I just gotta
put down the GoPro once in a while you
got on my show
does that being such an introvert and
making something happen well there's
meeting the people dancing with somebody
or just having fun see on the other side
EDC has a lot of attractions of riots
you can go on but I think I'm still too
shy to go by myself
this is probably the worst song to
listen to because it's about meeting
your ex one last time
but ironically during strangers there's
this girl behind me we couldn't see the
stage so to challenge my introvert Innes
I decided to offer her a shoulder ride
we ended up dancing a little bit from
Maddie on set and I never thought in a
million years that my intravenous would
be able to do this but here we are and
as Madeon was finishing up I heard
rumors that the secret guest for the
kelie of the art car was cascade so
naturally I had a runoff sadly though
the girl didn't want to come along
because she had a meet up with their
friends so I ended my EDC journey where
I started alone but at least with a ton
of memories and experiences that I'll
never forget
oh my gosh my bed I had so much fun this
whole trip got to see every single DJ I
wanted to see and really had the freedom
to just explore all the stages in the
whole place about myself they're worse
ups and downs you know being super sad
watching the part of Robson and crying
to him but I think he could have been
because his music is just so beautiful
still like having goosebumps thinking
about her right now
ah I've learned that easy is probably
the best place to go by yourself because
everyone that you meet there is so
inclusive and they're so loving and
happy and joyful and everyone there is
just there for the music I am probably
gonna go again next year if you do see
me my buddy
come say hi I promise I won't be shy
this time
[Music]
you
[Music]